all right let's show that efficient
algorithms can be simulated with
circuits with only small loss
in the circuit size namely time t can be
simulated by
boolean circuits of size t loc t to
remind you
we have two models of computation we
have the standard model of three
machines on the left hand side here
you have finite programmed
telling the machine what to do given uh
what state it's n which symbol it looks
and scans on the tape how to change the
state
what to write instead of the symbol on
the tape and how to move the tape hat
one position to the right one position
to the left and so forth
and at some point after two steps of
computation a turing machine this
algorithm is supposed to terminate
with accepting or rejecting accepting or
rejecting the input x
a circuit on the other hand simulating
this machine will have to have a falling
behavior
it has a bunch of bits x1 for xn
given as input of the circuit and it has
a bunch of
logical gates negations ors
ends and it must produce the output
of the computation in one of the gates
one of the nodes of this circuit
in the picture in the bottom one it has
to be one if the algorithm
accepted the input x and 0 otherwise and
the size of the circuit is the number of
gates
so we want to say that time t
corresponds to size t log t
so more precisely what we need to do
is to show that we can transform
between machine description to a circuit
description
in a way that the circuit size
is t lock t
so i want a transformation that will map
an input length n
to a circuit with n inputs c
on x one three x n such that for any
input set of length then
if machine v accepts that the generation
accepts that then the circuit
must be one on the input z
how do we construct the circuit so
basically we want to faithfully simulate
the tune machine the only way to
faithfully
simulate the tree machine that we know
is to open up
the turing machine and see how the
computation
evolves over the t steps of the tuning
machine's computation
and then try to simulate the tuning
machine basically step by step
with some circuitry and as you shall see
the reason we can do such a
transformation
is because the computational between
machine is
very local
so let's look at the transcript of the
of computation
of our machine v on some input set
where that is a binary string of length
n so
here i give you a snap snapshot of some
time steps of computation
the time goes from step zero when just
begin the computation to the next time
step one time step 2
and so forth until the end time step t
of n and as you shall see as
you see in this first tape contents
we're starting in the initial state q
naught we're looking at the leftmost
symbol of
set which is one so we have q1
q0 looking at the symbol one
and i put both the state and the symbol
on the tape
into one and i think of this as a
generalized sample
of the generalized tape symbol and then
the rest of the tape contains symbols
like 0
1 0 1 and so forth
and let's say the machines program is
like this which says that if i'm in
state cannot and i see one then
i erase the symbol keep my state to be
q naught and move to the right
and if i'm in zero if i'm in keynote and
i see a zero then i replace the 0 by 2
change my state from q 0 to q 1 and
still move right
and this 2 trans these two transitions
i reflected in my description of the
computation state at time 1 and time 2
you see i was in q0 i was scanning a 1
according to my transition i need to
replace this one with a blank symbol
which happens here and move one position
to the right so now
my new tape symbol is q zero followed by
zero
and similarly the second step i replace
the zero by two
and again move to the right and so forth
okay so how do we build a circuit out of
this
one idea is to first
do encoding of all the tape symbols
generalized tape symbols as i mentioned
and everything can be coded in binary so
you assign
bit strings of finite length to each
generalized symbol on the tape the
strings
that you need will be of constant bit
size
because the tape alphabet of my turing
machine is by definition some constant
size
and the number of states on my turing
machine is by definition
of constant size so i only need
constantly many bits
to represent all of those things in
binary
okay so i imagine that in each of these
tape cells i write down binary
representation of the symbols in those
cells okay like so
and then i need to compute
the value of the encodings of the
symbols
in the next time step in type step time
step
one for example what do i need to do
as usual as you see in this picture the
only thing that
changes are this
part of the tape so
because i was looking here with my tape
head
and that tape cell could have changed
and it did change in this case
and also my neighbor on the right i've
changed it went from symbol 0 to symbol
q
0 0 everything else stayed the same
so i could have just you know left these
things
alone and only focus
on this part of the tape which does the
chain which does
change so let's uh
think about what we need to do in order
to compute
the description of the next tape
the symbols on the next tape in time
step one
if i need to know this
symbol over here then of course
i need to know the symbol that is in the
same position in the previous time
step and i may need to know
the neighbor of that symbol on the left
or the neighbor of that symbol on the
right
so all i need to know is this
triple of symbols in order to determine
the symbol down one symbol down
and i can compute how this triple of
symbols
translate using the transition of my
tuning machine
and build a transformation that will map
the encodings of three symbols into the
encoding of one symbol
and i call this a circuit
f it's a transformation that takes
in as inputs three encodings of the
three symbols
at time step zero and outputs
down below the encoding of the symbol
in the appropriate position which here
will be
q 0 0
and the only thing you need to know in
order to build such a circuit is that
every boolean every function on
n variables can be computed by a boolean
circuit
of size at most 2 to the n in this case
the circuit is multi-output circuit
but the number of outputs is not that
big
and even though in general circuits
can be exponentially big in terms of the
input size
in our case the input
is of constant size because of the
alphabet size being constant number of
states being constant in the tuning
machine
so the circuit for computing this
transformation f
also will be even though exponential and
constant but still at most constant in
size
okay so the size of f
is constant
that's great now
if i want to compute the symbol at this
position over here
then i also need to plug in the same
kind of circuit like a copy of the same
circuit
that will compute the symbol in this
position
by looking at the appropriate triple of
symbols in the previous time step
and in general since i don't know as the
computation progresses i don't know
where the
action is going to be happening where my
tape hat is located
i'm forced to put a bunch of copies of
the circuits
like so in all positions
uh for the symbols in the next time step
okay and if i put all of the circuits
together
and apply them to the encodings of
symbols at time step 0
then i will collect at the bottom of
this
sequence of circuits f the encodings of
the generalized tape symbols
at time step 1. if i want to go from
time step one to time step two i do the
same thing
and i put a bunch of such
transformations such circuits
in a row in one level below
like so okay and i keep doing this
until time step t and then at the bottom
i will collect the description of the
last
uh snapshot of the computation on my tv
machine
and i can just check if it reached
accepting state or not whether it should
accept or not
okay so that's how i get a circuit for
the steering machine
and let's see what the size of the
circuit is going to be first of all the
number of steps
is at most t of n so the number of the
number of levels
in this circuit that i'm building will
be at most t
and the width of the circuit that i'm of
circuit i'm building is also going to be
at most roughly t
uh big o of t of n because in time t
uh my machine can only walk for at most
t steps in one position and most two
steps in another position
so be generous and say it will walk
no more than two t of n positions for
example
so the width is t the depth is t
and each circuit f is of constant size
which
gives me the complexity
side of the whole circuit to be big o
of t square
and that's not what i promised i
promised you t-lock t
so how can we do better
well to do better we need special kinds
of tuning machines which are called
oblivious turing machines
what is an oblivious turing machine it's
a wonderful
algorithm uh which hides
uh can obfuscate his behavior in some
sense
what happens is for every input z of
size n
the position of the tape head of the
turing machine
is independent of a particular input set
it's only a function of the input length
n
which means that if you look at the
trajectory that the tape head of your
turing machine
goes through during the computation on
an
e on a given input of size n it will be
the exact same trajectory
for any other input of the same input
size n
okay so how does it
help us well let's go back and look at
the transcript of the computation of
an oblivious string machine and
for simplicity of presentation i'm only
focusing on the case of
one tape oblivious to a machine which
honestly doesn't exist
um you need to have two tape
jury machine for that as i'll mention in
a moment
but it will just complicate my drawing
so let me
just stick with the not completely
truthful
representation of an one tape oblivious
tuning machine for this presentation
so here we know
where we'll be scanning which symbols
will be scanning
at every time step and
those positions are fixed the
independent of a particular input
they're just a function of an input
length m
so if i know that the action is going to
be happening around this positions
then i only need to put the
transformation f around the same
positions
okay so the only thing that will change
is this
two positions here and then
these two positions over here that's
where the changes will be happening
because
my tape head is my
my tape head is moving to the right both
of those times
so knowing where it's going to be i know
which two symbols on the tape i need to
pay attention
to and change and so i need to i can
draw
a transformation which transforms this
two tape cell encodings
to the new tape cell encodings and i can
do so
using uh some new transformation let me
call it
g and then i have a copy of g
for the next time step and so forth
and when i don't have g basically what
i'm doing is
i'm allowing just straight lines
okay so i just connect the
output the encodings at time step 0
with straight wires uh to
the encoding so the symbol set time step
one the symbols don't change so i don't
need to perform any computation i just
copy
and so i have a bunch of wires going
down
uh where i where no action is happening
no computation
is happening and recommendations
happening i have my
circuit g of constant size because it
depends only on two tape
uh type symbols okay
and so this is what's happening so i
have a circuit which is very sparse now
to go from time step one to time step
one i need only one copy of g
and this g as before because it maps
constant number of bits to constant
number of bits
can be implemented in constant size
the size of the circuit for g is of
constant is a constant
and i how many such copies of g do i
need
well at most t of n because the length
of the computation is t of n
and i do one copy of g per time step
so now my size
of the overall circuit is at most
constant size of each g times t of n
as opposed to t square because
now the width is very small very narrow
okay so basically we know where the
action is happening so we put the
computation device
just in those places and those places
are the same for all inputs of given
length so we're not losing any
information
and we know that everywhere else we can
just copy the information from one time
step to the next time step
without losing anything and so this
gives us a much better much smaller
circuit size
the only thing is that we need to start
our transformer tuning machine into an
oblivious one
and nobody's promised us an oblivious
tuning machine to begin with
but fortunately it it can always be done
and this is a very old result from
late 60s early 70s by pippinjar fisher
and earlier work of henny and stearns
who've shown that every time t algorithm
can be made into equivalent
oblivious time to look t algorithm
more precisely they show that if you
start with
any tree machine that runs in time t of
n and the chain machine may have some
constant number k of tapes
2 three five
uh has an equivalent to a machine that
only has
two tapes and the running time of the
new
equivalent machine is t lock t and the
new machine
is oblivious one so its trajectories of
tape
head positions uh are independent of the
particular inputs and only a function of
the input length
okay so this is an amazing result this
is a very interesting algorithm
and it's a construction so you can
take the description of the procedure
from those papers and apply them to your
particular training machine
which is not oblivious and make it into
an equivalent oblivious machine
with only logarithmic factor loss in
time complexity
okay i will not give this proof just
take it as given
the corollary of this is that we can now
take
our time t train machine computation
make it into oblivious two tape time t
loc
t computation and then
given an oblivious machine of running
time t log t
when we build a circuit from from it the
way that i described
the size of the circuit will be pretty
much the same as the number of
time steps of the new machine the new
machine has
t log t time steps so the size of the
circuit is
big o of t log t and that's how we get
that
time t can be simulated by size uh t log
t
one thing i didn't mention and i don't
wanna spend too much
on this is the two tape
tube machine versus one tape turing
machine
uh the definition of two machine i gave
you was for simplicity just one tape
and you have a finite control the state
and you look at
this tape you can imagine several tapes
like two
and you're scanning independently some
positions on two of those tapes
and then based on the information in
those two tapes you decide what to do
next which means
how you update the information in those
locations on the two tapes
what new state you enter and how you
move independently
on tape one and tape two so you can go
left on one and right on the other
and so forth and the construction for
the circuit for two tape machine
follows the same structure as the one
tape construction that i described
you just have to imagine that you have
another snapshot of
computation of of the tuning machine for
the second tape
okay and you you kind of trace
how that second tape evolves the same
way as you trace how the first tape
evolves
and when you compute this transformation
g
um you also need to know what was
happening on the other tape
because the transition function of your
turing machine the program of your
tuning machine
depends on the information on both tapes
so the circuits
g will have as inputs the information
coming from
appropriate circuits g prime for the
second tape and similarly the circuits
for g
prime will have to have as inputs some
information coming from the circuits g
for the second tape but that's not very
difficult
conceptual it's pretty straightforward
to do
okay so that concludes the proof that
time t can be simulated in size t log t
now let's go back to proving the np
completeness of three sat
so remember i promised you that if you
give me language l
in non-mystic time t then i can
build a 3 cnf of size
roughly t log t such that
the input is in the language if and only
if the appropriate
3c f that is in the output of my
reduction
of size t log t is satisfiable okay
let's see how we can do that a given
language l in logistic time
t means that i have a verifier
that has input x and description of
witness
y where the length of y is
t of the length of x and the length of x
let's say so
n and the run of the verifier is
big o of t of n so i have a
deterministic algorithm running in time
t
of n and what i want
is to build the 3cnf what i can do
already given the description of
the transformation from algorithms to
circuits that i've shown you earlier
is that for every input length n we can
efficiently
in polynomial time construct a circuit c
that will faithfully simulate my
algorithm in this case
it's algorithm v on inputs x and y
so i'll have a circuit which has inputs
x and y
such that the algorithm v accepts if and
only if the circuit
outputs one on the inputs x and y and
the size of the circuit is small
it's going to be at most t log t from
what we've shown earlier
now it's very simple so for every x
by the definition of l we know that x
is a yes instance of a language l of a
problem
l if and only if there exists a witness
y
that makes the verifier v on x and y
accept
since the circuit faithfully simulates
the verifier it's the same as there
there exists a y such that the circuit c
on inputs x
and y outputs one and now let's define
the circuit
c sub x so that the inputs to the
circuit c sub x are just
bits in y okay c sub x of y is defined
as
c of x and y so i just take an x and
hardwire into the circuit
and the only three variables left in my
circuit system the y's
it shows it follows that my circuit c
sub x is satisfiable if and only if
input acts as a language and the size of
the circuit c sub x which is at most the
size of the circuit c
is still at most t log t
okay so what we've shown is a reduction
which maps an input x of length x
to circuit c backs of length t log t
such that x is in the language if and
only if circuit c is satisfiable
what does this show it shows that the
problem circuit sat
is np complete okay please and the hard
so we get a reduction from any problem
in np
to circuit satisfiability circuit
satisfiability is of course the same as
very similar to three satisfiability
except that
what we're given is not a three cnf but
a circuit so we're given the description
of this graph
with inputs and some gates and we need
to know if there exists an input to the
circuit
which makes the output gate say one so
that circuit satisfiability problem
it's nnp because you can always guess an
input to the circuit which makes it
satisfied and then evaluate the circuit
in following
time in the size of the circuit and the
reduction
shown just now approves the np-hardness
part
that every problem in np can reduce to
circuit sat
but that's not what we wanted right uh
we wanted to show
that three starters empty complete
cochlear's theorem that's easy to
achieve now
with a simple extra reduction which maps
circuit satisfiability to 3sat
so what we need to do we need to take a
circuit c
as shown here let's say on any inputs
and we need to output a three cnf
formula that i denote by phi sub c
with the property of the reduction c so
that's fine i believe and only if the
formula phi sub c is satisfiable
and like before when we transform the
transmission computation the transcript
of three machine computation
into a circuit using locality of the
computation of the tuning machine
here we use the quality of the
computation of the circuit
okay so here's how how we will do this
we'll basically introduce for each gate
of the circuit a prepositional variable
okay so we'll label each gate
with some variable let's say g1
g2 g3
g4 g
m minus 1 gm
here i'm thinking of m as the size of
the circuit
and then we just need to say that these
variables
for the gates are assigned correctly
given the assignment of variables that
are inputs to those case
so what i mean to say is for example
that g1
which is the negation of x1 must be
equivalent to
not x1
[Music]
g2 must be equivalent to
g1 concatenated
with x2 and so forth
and also we need to say that the last
gate gm
is equivalent to one it's it's true okay
so now we need to impose this conditions
over all gates on our circuit which
basically
tells you that the value of the gate is
correct given the values of the inputs
to the gate
and you do these big conjunctions over
big conjunction overall gates and in
your circuit
and this will give you a formula which
will be satisfiable
so the input of this formula will be
both the variables
x and the variables
g and the formula will be satisfiable if
and only if
there is a way to set the axis so that
the values of the gates
will be correct and the output gate
will say one okay
one small thing to worry about
here is that it's not exactly 3cnf
yet i've written here
conditions which look like
equivalences but those equivalences
involve at most three variables each
okay the first one involves only two
variables the second one involves three
variables
and the last one involves only one
variable so these are conditions on at
most three variables
these are some boolean conditions and at
most three variables some logical
conditions
and anything on three variables you can
equivalently express as a three cnf
in a fairly straightforward way okay so
each one of these conditions you can
translate into an equivalent
at most three cnf at most 3c enough
means that
the width of the clauses in your cmf is
at most free
and then you take the conjunctions of
this uh at most three cnfs and get a new
atmosphere cnf which will be the output
of the reduction from circuit set to
three sat
size of this three cnf that we get this
way will be
proportional to the number of gates in
this circuit because that's how many
conditions we'll introduce and then each
condition will
replace by a three cnf of constant size
so the size of the three cnf that you
end up with is big o of the size of the
circuit
the circuit was t log t as you remember
when i when we did the translations from
turing machine computation of complexity
t to
a circuit and now we transform that
circuit into a cnf
a three c and f of the same size and
that's how you get finally
the conclusion that given end time t of
n computation
you can get a three c and f of size at
most t
log which is satisfiable if and only if
input x of length n is in the language
one last side remark i need to make
about this
is that i talked about
cnfs which have clauses or width at most
three
and then when i define the problem three
start
those cnfs were assumed to have all
clauses of size exactly
three okay so that's not very difficult
to fix now
if i have some clauses which have with
smaller than three then i can always
introduce some new
fresh variable z it to the clause
positively and negatively
and replace a clause of size two with
conjunction of two clauses of size three
and this transformation can be easily
seen
to preserve satisfiability the close on
the left is satisfiable i believe only
if
the conjunction of the two clauses on
the right is satisfiable and so i can
always
introduce some dummy variables and make
my
atmosphere cnf into satisfiability
equivalent
exactly three cnf
okay so to summarize what we've shown is
a time t computation can be simulated by
size t log t circuits in particular as a
corollary
we get that polynomial time can be
simulated by polynomial size circuits
what does it mean it means that if we
can show that
problem 3 sat does not have polynomial
size circuits
namely threesat cannot be done by
polynomial sizeable and circuits
then obviously threesat cannot be done
by polynomial time algorithms
so the circuit lower bound is much
stronger than just showing that
three sat is not in polynomial time and
this simple observation saying that
circuit lower bounds is sufficient for
proving that p is different from np is a
huge motivation
for this whole area of circuit
complexity that is actively pursued by
complexity theories
our goal is to prove some strong circuit
lower bound for
a difficult problem like satisfiability
uh our success uh
has been pretty limited
to be generous okay but we'll
see some things that we can do and how
it relates to
algorithmic complexity of satisfiability
in next videos